good afternoon good morning hello
everyone and welcome to our live
epigenetics focused webinar titled
performing chip using low amounts of
frozen mouse brain tissue an
investigation of how stress alters 5hmc
by mediating transcription factor
binding presented by CC Lee from the
University of Wisconsin today's webinar
is brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by Polaris my name is Shaun
Guerin I am the epigenomics product
manager at kouvaris and also today's
moderator joining me today is my
colleague dr. Hameed koja principal
scientist who will be will be available
to answer your questions at the end
along side with Cici Hameed has
extensive experience in the field of
epigenetics and is always going to help
our customers before we begin I'd like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive please feel free to submit
as many questions as you would like at
any time during the presentation to ask
a question simply click into ask a
question box type your question and
click send all questions will be
answered at the end of today's
presentation during our dedicated Q&A
session you may also submit questions
during the on-demand period and your
questions will be answered via email
just a note to enlarge the slides simply
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the slide window if you
are having trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation at any time today please
click on the support tab found on the
top right corner of the presentation
window or report your problem by
clicking on the answer a question box
located on the far left corner of your
screen now we taking care of all the
administrative things I'd like to
introduce our presenter CC Lee CC Lee
finished the neuroscience PhD training
program at the university of
wisconsin-madison where she completed
her graduate research in the lab of dr.
reid alesh her research focused on the
role of the environmentally sensitive
novel epigenetic mark
5-hydroxymethylcytosine in response to
stress leading leading to nourish
neuropsychiatric disorders cece has
produced three Co first author
publications has released seven
publications over her research career
and has given numerous oral and poster
presentations
across the country her final
dissertation work was focused on
developing a deeper understanding of the
molecular mechanisms linking stress 5hmc
and transcription factor binding using
chromatin immunoprecipitation before we
begin today's presentation I'd like to
extend the warmest congratulations to CC
on behalf of everyone at kouvaris for
successfully completing her oral thesis
defense last month it's a fantastic
accomplishment and we're very happy and
excited for her as she continues to
progress in her career as a scientist
without further ado I'd like to hand the
presentation over to CC to begin the
presentation Thank You shant about very
conscious and I am CC the presenter at a
very excited to talk to everyone today
about my dissertation research which is
on an investigation of how stress alters
transcription factor binding by
mediating side agencies so stress can
cause psychiatric disorders and some
risk factors are environmental factors
stressors such as childhood trauma
maternal separation malnutrition another
big big factor is genetics Survey's are
these really important genes in those
stress responds and when these genes are
disrupted in their gene expression or
protein function
these can lead to psychiatric disorders
such as anxiety depression PTSD now one
in five adults in America experience of
mental illness so this is a huge problem
and it's not just in America but all
over the world but one way that these
environmental stressors can disrupt
functions of genes is through
epigenetics now what is epigenetics I
defined phonetics as the modifications
that are a B so on top of the genome
that may cause functional alterations to
gene expression and DNA structure
without changing the nucleotides
themselves and so here we have a
chromosome and what you do min you see
that there are DNA wrapped round beads
of proteins collagen
they have tails that can be closed
transcriptionally in modified so this is
a domain called system application
another domain of epigenetics is where
you do minion further to the nucleotide
level there are these methyl groups that
can attach on to side of things and that
those are the most the two most common
the study methyl groups are five MC and
5hmc and so 5 MC 5 methylcytosine it's
just as simple as another group attached
deciding but in 2009 it was rediscovered
that the shell wheels enzyme is called
Ted so many enzymes can very very
environmentally sensitive can actually
convert 5 methylcytosine to
5-hydroxymethylcytosine which is the
mark that of my thesis is based on and
so these marks can actually affect
transcription so here's is a protein or
transcription factor which is
approaching that our recognizes of
sequence of DNA called the binding sites
or is this and different transcription
factors have different binding sequences
that they bind to and so this protein
can recognized of sequence and bind to
it and cost transcription at no later
installation and size MC in fact agency
can modify the binding of the
transcription factors and therefore
modify transcription
and so five agency and five empty
there's a lot of differences between
them and here's an example in human
embryonic stem cells so on the Left we
have an immuno chemistry staining of
five agency on so this is chromatin and
then the second panel is 5mc of in red
and we'll universe two images on the
last image you can actually see that the
distribution of five agency and 5mc are
very different so five agency is mostly
on the arm of the chromosome working
expression gene coding are and five
agency is mostly packed in the middle
where it's near the pair ascension exit
of regions where the DNA is very densely
packed and so others saying other
features of our agency that makes it a
marker a very important marker is that
it's actually tenfold more enriched in
the central nervous system compared to
the peripheral tissue of the body and
mate so they were making it a really
promising marker to study brain related
disorders it's also been actively
associated solution in the brain it's a
sense of re-emergence in research and
children's and ninth it's already been
involved in neurodevelopmental and as
well as neurodegenerative disorders and
the family of enzymes the test family
enzymes that convert v MC into 5hmc are
actually extremely environmentally
sensitive
and so a visual example of this here is
so this is a literal mice that are it's
the same v6 measure from the same letter
and when they were born they were all
dis golden color and as you add vitamin
b12 also know as folic acid and it's a a
month of donor just in their drinking
water so just in their diet so the
methyl donor is an important part of
joining methylation you can have you
increase the amount of vitamin b12 added
to their diet of their coat color
actually changes and gets darker and
darker and so this is an example a
visual example of how they can see or
how an environmental factor such as diet
can actually change of change in a ser
visible way of throw a lifetime of mouse
and so in my research we decided up to
study how stress affects audacious Nia
may lead to psychiatric disorders
we chose a very established stress
paradigm and in our stress group we have
a 30 minute restraint control um as I'm
an hour of recovery third and then the
mass sacrifice and we investigate how
stress can disrupt our five agency
compared to the control group and so we
can't talk about stress without talking
about the HPA axis and how that
regulates just so the
hypothalamic-pituitary-adrenal axis is
initiated 1a external session is
detected by an organism and that causes
the activation of the height
hypothalamus to after the torturer to
actually lead reno to create cortisol
and cortisol can actually go back and
bind to loop recorder corey receptors in
the hippocampus which is a research site
study and the binding of the Scherzo to
the receptors initiate and negative
feedback mechanism therefore on their
first dampening or stopping the
activation of HPA axis
however when you have in the blue where
there are less work with protocol
receptors in particularly in the
hippocampal and ESPA campus and bring
you're going to have less negative
feedback there for a prolonged
activation of the HP axis which can lead
to of detrimental effects later on and
the cooper corticoid gene is called NR 3
c1 and when we looked at the citation
see and how stress effective rates are
agency on this particular gene we found
that a cue stress actually causes about
a two-fold increase in hydration feed in
this very important gene of the group of
protocol receptor gene and r3q on
and so that led us to think that perhaps
there are since there are many genes
involved in the stress pathway there
must be other genes that are affected by
stress and we want to know how stress
affects these different genes across the
whole genome so we use a selective
labeling purification and genomic
location mapping outside section 3
technique to see where if I Regency is
located and control animals compared to
animals that have been stressed and so
this is actually pretty similar chip I'm
just going to go over it quickly so if
you want to Nene and that we segment it
into on 300 base pairs and the red lines
are the ones that contain 5 agency also
there's an enrichment of it and then a
group is Modi is tacked on to the 5
agency and biotin is focus Modi and then
we can use affinity purification to pull
out only the fragments that are enriched
in five agency and sequence this across
the whole genome and figure out where if
I we can see is in a cultural animals
compared to the restraint animals so
what we're interested in our regions
with increase or decrease of agency in
response to an acute stress so for
example here this is a snapshot of a of
the UCSC genome browser and on top we
have control our thirty-two animals and
at the bottom our restraint animals so
this region that that's a box in red
would be a region which was increased
vibration see due to stress the
restraint stress and this region that
just popped up would be a decrease of
asad HMC on a response to stress and so
when we looked at all of the regions
across the whole genome which we see
here in this Manhattan plot where the
the x-axis are the chromosome and the Y
axes just tells you how how different it
changes it changes our film control and
so you
and first you can see that every point
on this graph is a place where there is
five agency detected and so across our
agency is present across the whole
genome and anything above the red line
or below the the red dashed line and
below the green dashed line our
significant region with increased or
decreased by urgency as you can see that
you know we're going to queue stress of
thirty minutes five agency is changing
significantly across the whole genome
and when we looked at these um we looked
at these regions and the actual
nucleotides are in sequences in this
region we found that there are
transcription factor binding sites in
these regions with vibration feed
disruption and so these transcription
factor binding sites are commonly called
boxes we divided them into motifs in
regions with an increase in region see a
motif in regions with decreased
vibration see and so here are the are
similar potential on binding sites and
we also found that these binding sites
are predicted to bind transcription
factors that are already related stress
so we want to know if an acute stress
can actually cause a change in
transcription factor binding and so we
had to select the top transcription
factor to test this question out and so
we had many different criterias for
selecting a transcription factor such as
a first of all as it expresses a brain
is expressed in The Tempest is important
for developing neuron is it associated
with a head Catterick disorder 3 so the
one that we picked is match 3 and so you
can see smash 3 contest is binding site
next to it and it has a really nice
complex concepts with five inside of 8
base pairs of making it up
a greater chance that we would find it's
not three binding to this and we also
needed to pick a gene to test this out
with and so from all the genes that are
disrupted due to an acute stress we also
conducted RNA what we're interested in
is also gene expression changes and not
just vibration C changes and we did RNA
sequencing using the same from the same
tissue and the same animal same tissue
and we found the set of differential
expression and we overlapped that with
the set of differential equation C and
we found 11 genes that contain changes
in both vibration C and gene expression
due to an acute stress and so here are
the gene diagrams of these 11 genes that
contain changes in both separated by
upregulated genes section and
downregulated gene expression and when
you will we when I looked at these genes
and of all of them and just what
functions they had I actually found that
six of these genes have been associated
with stress already and when I looked at
the sequences in DNA sequences in the
binding of and the regions that are
differentially hydroxyl methylated in
these a lot of genes I found that all 11
of these genes actually had significant
in significant universe transcription
factors binding sites and so however
what night a had a transcription factor
binding site of smash 3 which is a
transcription factor that we had chosen
and so on so 1 9 a and snap 3 were
chosen together to give me the best
chance to answer the question does
stress affect for sure factors binding
so here you can see that but what 9n
contains a smattering binding sites and
which is highlighted in yellow and all
of the PG sites that are highlighted in
green around it are our site on the
nucleotide where there could be five
agency two kinds of changes and so
naturally the question is does Stratis
alteration through factor and may and
this alteration may be mediated by size
agency just there are so many binding
sites near it and the method we chose to
investigate this question was using
chromatin chromatin immunoprecipitation
so chip and so here's just a little
overview of chip
first you want cross-linked two
transcription factors in to the genomic
DNA and so for example it's not very
mighty down to DNA and that we want to
cross link though so they're together
chop it up into about 300 base pairs and
some of these of some of these DNA
segments will be bound by snap three and
then we used a antibody that's literally
tacked on to snap three to pull out only
regions that are bound by smash three
and on eluded DNA and did of the
identity PCR but you could also do
sequencing genome wide sequencing with
us and so the covariance protocol
focuses tissue tissue workflow is the
first you have harvest your tissue in my
cases at the campus as well we section
the tissue
six-two tissue um we can use since it's
tissue we can pulverise it and then the
prepared the nuclei share the chromatin
and that underlies this year and to see
if it's good quality DNA and so the
tissue tissue sample workflow there are
a couple very important steps that needs
that should be focused on first is the
the sixty
formaldehydes second is the cryo faction
issue with the cryo top and then there's
the nuclear exhalation process and
lastly it's a chromatin sharing and
these does all may need to be optimized
depending on what tissue you are
planning on using and so what is your
preparation here are some tips for
triple low amounts of frozen brain
tissue brain tissue is very difficult to
do to work with and so what I do is I
use intracardiac perfusion to wash away
the blood using very ice cold PBS and so
here you can see a picture of a fresh
spring versus a bring perfuse of with
PBS to wash away the blood so there's a
very big difference there and timing is
also key so you want to do this as fast
and as cold as possible to preserve the
biomolecules so then I take out the
tempers and then I flash freeze it and
another tip is that you want to ensure
that the buffers that are that may
precipitate are are ocular heated and
the precipitants are dissolved you wanna
make sure that they're at room
temperature before you add it to any of
your tissue and so on the critical steps
of cutting tissue and tissue samples and
very small amount is so I'm planning on
publishing a method paper based on fist
so this is all the tools that I use to
get a from so I use of a capsule tissue
which is about 30 to 40 milligrams an
adult melt of plastics mice and so I can
get about from a 30 to 40 milligrams of
tissue about three to four milligrams of
protein so that's a lot of mouths brain
tissue
so that's that's actually a lot and
another critical step is um tissue
pulverization
so this is the part where you use
pulverizer and um and this is um so you
want to make sure again that the tissue
is kept very cold and sometimes there
could be pancakes like formations of
suggesting in the picture on the right
and so what I do is just I use my index
finger and my thumb to quickly squeeze
it like that you can feel if there's any
of any numbers or substance and if there
is then just um just repeat the process
in the protocol until it's powder like
and and then again of keep it as cold as
possible so dip it back into looks and
oxygen about every 10 seconds you think
it's going to start to sell and I also
and to get most of the dish the tissue I
transfer it directly to our centrifuge
tube and so the critical sense of trip
is performing fixation cell lysis and
chromatin sharing and so for the
fixation this is very very important
step you want to use methanol screen
formaldehyde so I make the 16 of I make
the 1 percent formaldehyde from the 16
percent of muscle no free from aldehyde
and then I actually make that right
before I add it to the tissue um and
just to make sure that you're getting
all the tissue and and the least amount
of tissue up if you're seeing that
they're active integration that there's
tissue loss you can always increase it
increase the centrifuge speed by about
20 percent and you do not want to use
the commonly sold 30 percent from
aldehyde that has about 50 percent
methanol
and so the importance of formaldehyde
that is that it's free of methanol can
be seen here so in Figure one is fresh
formaldehyde fixed at room temperature
and I think these are these ourselves
and and if you spike that fresh methanol
with 1.5 percent that fresh from
aldehyde with 1.5 percent methanol you
can see that it's already over fixed and
over succession can also increase your
cause over cross linking which can
increase your i GG background which is a
commonly used as a background negative
control so amok IP and so um my test for
MS eating low amounts of brain tissue so
why is bring tissues so hard to work
with as you can see on the chart on the
left so this is processed all the same
way but using liver tissue muscle tissue
and brain tissue and you get the lowest
yield from brain tissue so first most of
all who are working with animal brain
tissue are working with mice or um or
bad brain tissue and so you just have
very low tissue quality to start with
and the weight of these tissue may vary
by strength by a lot actually bring
tissue is soft South County vary in
different tissue types depending on what
region of the brain you're interested in
and the amount of the transcription
factor or histone marker that you are
investigating is also extremely
important for example on you it's a
really good idea to actually it's um
it's great to do an epitope integrity
test so what we did was we um because
over fixation can cost over
cross-linking and rock and block the
epitopes that your antibody is trying to
tag onto so what I did was I had size
different tiny points of fixation so
from 5 minutes to 20 minutes um and I
use the western black out region the
same antibody to
to check that my other toes are still
intact and and bring tissue is also hard
because neurons are surrounded by Milan
this fat layer that disrupts fixation
and also sonication making it harder to
to work with and even cutting so cutting
brain tissue into into similar tongue
sizes of very fast before it sells it's
almost impossible and these neuronal
proteins are also sensitive to
temperature changes and so the major
difference between working with cultured
cells and small masses of tissue is that
in cultured cells you have a single
layer of cells as is grown and so the
fixation is very even versus using a
razor blade and in my case is cutting
the hippocampus two equal sized pieces
you can see that below the hippocampal
picture is the brain and so the this is
this is a full adult mouth spring and
it's it's very small to begin with and
I'm lucky to be working with the
hippocampus because it's actually it's
it's you can straight you can detect it
out straight from a fresh spring like
touches the picture demonstrate film 1
to 7 so you're working with a tiny
amount of tissue here and also within
the hippocampus there are many different
kinds of cell types and so um you've got
and also myelin because there's a lot of
connections as well and so that makes
working with tissue much harder without
working with cell culture
and some critical steps that I optimize
for the nuclei preparation is that is
over even to 200 microlitre one suppose
where I just rinsed the bags that was
400 microliters of bumper and I also
dilute the of the 130 microliter of
lysate after sonication with the IP
buffer and I spin it down for 10 minutes
at max speed at 4°c and so that's going
to precipitate all of the debris and
give you a much cleaner lysate sample to
work with you on just transfer that into
a you tube and you have you will have a
much cleaner ship so here are some data
from my own practice samples so these
are practice m plus 1 2 3 and then you
can and the settings on the curve errors
so I used as through 20 and the settings
are seen on the lower right corner and
so this is a very reducible result and
when you zoom in on this sample number
one this is what I got when I when I
diluted my 16% as a last mile free from
aldehyde ethyl and then I created a 1%
from other solution and fix it for 8
minutes
and so coming back to my project like
respond to remind everyone that um this
is um that we are interested in how
stress affects transcription factor
binding of snuff three to the what nine
aging and so here looking here is the
qPCR that I did and this is data from
from my lab and so on the right we used
adulthood Mocambo tissue we rinse the
blood which of cardiac T we used one
percent methanol free ample and the
flash shows the hippocampus fixed at
room temperature for just eight minutes
I thought I did it with the s to 24
eight minutes as well and what you see
here is that um so the blue um the blue
bar and the grey bar come from the same
animal and it's the in
immunoprecipitated and the edge D
background control and then the red bar
is our cute restrains from animal and um
the white bar is the icy control for
that and so first you can see that the I
usually controls are very low in this in
this graph meaning that um there is not
over fixation and that there's a
significant difference between um
between my control IP and my control IgG
of meaning however work but when your
focus on is that there's a significant
difference as well between the control
and the restraint stress so that means
that an acute stress of 30 minutes is
reducing the binding of snap 3 to what
nine a significantly
yes and so um we wondered why is this
happening how could an acute stress
reduce the binding of fat32 what neck
age and so could it be that acute stress
is affecting um dis mastery to protein
levels and so we asked the question is
the decrease in factor binding to month
at a caused by a decrease in smashed
three levels and so here I did a Western
blot of with my controls and my
restraint and duplicates and we found
that of totals mad is does not actually
change due to acute stress so s-- mad is
a protein that is activated by
phosphorylation and it actually can't
get into the nucleus it can be
translocated in the nucleus unless it's
phosphorylated and so the antibody that
i used for chip does not distinguish
between just inactive slab and active
smash however when we looked at
phosphorylated smash at tyrosine 179
position we saw that there was a
decrease in that 3 activation so was
sufferable aidid's magnus lust activated
less which means less fat in the nucleus
to bind to one night and that could be a
mechanistic explanation of why acute
stress is causing must be divided less
what 980 from our chip data and so
further on to tie all of this to 5
agency naturally we wanted to know does
5 agency disrupt mat binding to not one
night and for this we use of an electric
electrode product overly shift assay
cousin answer where we created pros of
wild-type probes about 30 base pair
containing of the what nice sequence
containing be snide binding sites and
then also a site dot could so that route
that was our wild-type row and that we
also created the same crow
but just with an additional modification
of salvation see and this is double
strand DNA and so these protons these
are only 30 based proposed at with the
binding site and well type versus run a
and we found that if you add saivation C
to this probe you get almost how
decrease of binding of fat32 to this
massive binding site and so five agency
is most likely causing that to be to be
boundless in the stress condition and in
addition to that we also we also made a
mutant um a mutant binding site so I
decide binding site again is eight
different of is eight nucleotides and I
mutated the first form you could hide so
at this clear position that just showed
up that there's no bend there meaning
that um if the mutant label does not
actually the mutant probe does not bind
not three
so with that I came up with a working
model of how money mystically and acute
stress could persist your five agency as
well as transcription factor binding and
how that could lead to gene expression
changes from my own data and so we so in
this version model you can see that on
top is the plasma membrane and then
below that is a nuclear membrane and
then the segment we have control what
Nanae segments and then acute stress my
mate one nine eight seven and then we
know from my own data that one night a
in response to acute stress there's an
increase of foundation C so the so the
red dot is an increase in hydrogen see
in the acute stress on section of this
chain and we also know that there is a
smog of binding sites that one night and
that's indicated by the green rectangle
um so we know from the data both of qpcr
data and the answer data that mastery of
there's a there's a decrease of binding
in factory and acute stress which means
that there's more binding of snap three
in the control control animals to its
binding site within what nine a we also
know from the literature that mecp2
which is meso CBG binding protein to its
approaching that binds v MC n side
agency it functions to block binding of
transcription factors that are kind of
bind to their transcription factor
binding sites so in the acute stress
case i'm needs to be two can be binding
to the foundation c of blocking
transcription factor from fighting
satlak suffering from binding to its
site and furthermore from our new
sequence data we know that there's a
decrease in gene expression and um and
and thus gene expression um so
so if there's a decrease in our gene
expression we're going to have foraging
expressions in the control and so
indicated by the figure in the control
and then also this will cause more gene
expression and lastly with the Western
blot data with acute stress causing a
decrease of that activation we can see
that there will remorse mad activators
mad in the control animals within the
nucleus sense of non phosphorylated snap
and the phosphorylation is indicated by
the yellow dots on this map protein
maltose really mad cannot translocate
into the nucleus so giving control
animals more of a chance to have have
more what 988 expression her two acute
stress animal and so this is all from my
own data and so since I was true years
on to how this could tie together into
into psychiatric disorders which is what
I'm really interested in I said I
investigated the one pathway so what 9 a
is a member in this big family of what
once members and the one pathway and
it's connected to psychiatric disorders
such as a major depressive disorder and
so looking in my own data and the
regions that have change inspiration see
I find that nd one that there are genes
in the us pathway that are that have
changes in our agency such as GSK
through beta it would ease other members
of the one family and these genes are
all already associated with stress
related psychotic disorder so to take
this a step further to take this up
further
I made a working model including the
literature that I found including this
one pathway and so what if you have more
expression you will have most likely
more protein translation and what 9a
actually goes out of the plasma membrane
but it blocks GSK 3 beta and Jesse 3
beta on blocks in its natural case
blocks beta catenin and beta catenin can
translocate into the nucleus and cost
transcription of wet night a however oh
and as well as a compute 1/2 and these
are all genes that are found within my
own data that have changes in 5 agency
AG t 1 and 2 can also inhibit just case
3 beta and so what I found in the
literature is that um jiske 3 beta um
increase and a Keke's decreased in
enzyme activity and post-mortems
suicide victims frames of with major
depression but not suicide victim brains
without major depression so so what is
happening with impatience with major
depression could be that there's an
increase in GSK through beta which means
that um it's more anxious
it's is um enzyme activity is higher so
it's blocking beta content in more and
blocking vidiq inin is going to it's
going to decrease the transcription of
what 9a and also a decrease in apts is
going to decrease its block operators of
jiske through beta and that's going to
even increase the activity of GSK
through beta more and that's going to
block beta glucan and more and therefore
Vivek unit is going to have you know
list of ability to turn to help with
transcription of one night a and perhaps
facilitates rapid binding and so an
extreme case of the my motto is a mouse
model after a 30 just a 30 minute
strides in one hour
cover a period and I'm already finding
all these changes but imagining in
extreme cases and humans where where
there is severe chronic stress that are
disrupting saivation see that may lead
to a full-blown psychiatric disorders as
guests of agency is responding so fast
to even such a small short stressor and
so
so with that I'd like to thank my
everyone in my lab everyone who helped
me I have been um I shall introduce I've
collaborate with 13 different labs and I
want to thank everyone in all those labs
helped me throughout my dissertation my
graduate school years of careers I like
to thank my thesis committee of and
funding and also everyone from Cabarrus
of course the very generous and giving
me this platform to speak out about my
research I like to take my program and
as well as my support system which is
very important and so chip actually took
me two years to UM to to do and two
years in size different labs and five
different protocols so you can imagine
during the fourth protocol um and a year
and a half into it I was pretty
desperate and thinking it's never going
to work but when I saw the seminars that
dr. Hameed puja presented at uw-madison
I that was the fifth protocol the
magical room how that actually made
everything work out work together and
incorporating all this data and and the
rest just fell into place
so um with that I just like to conclude
my portion and hand up in addition back
to Sean
see see thank you so much for your
highly informative presentation before
we begin our interactive Q&A session
with the audience like to take just a
few minutes to review polaris products
that can be used for your specific
applications kouvaris offers multiple
chromatin sample preparation reagent
kits to enable you to effectively
prepare samples for chip based
applications the troopship chromatin
sharing kits have been fully validated
for use on all polaris focus ultrasonic
gaiters to ensure reproducible results
when enriching for specific histone
modifications and transcription factors
of interest the troopship reagent kits
enable investigators to work with low
cell and low tissue mass inputs as we
saw today as well as high cell and high
mass inputs and as on the figure on the
right as you can see an increasing
number of peer-reviewed publications
continue to cite kouvaris due to the
high quality results achieved from our
optimized workflow and just some key
advantages to highlight a view of
pairing through chip with the kouvaris
adaptive focus acoustics technology
include the ability to the one of the
most critical thing is to maintain the
protein DNA interactions with an
optimized fixation strategy in
consumables so importantly the the
vessels that are made of glass which
minimizes heat buildup and allows the
samples to be processed without
disrupting those protein daily
interactions and this is an issue that's
offering car with plastic tubes due to
defective is or key and do not dissipate
as quickly and it's critically important
when working with low abundant epitopes
or histone marks and REO transcription
factors
another key advantage is the ability to
consistently share chromatin to the
correct size for sequencing the
distribution size is critical when
performing especially for chip seekin in
the for with high-throughput sequencing
and the standardization of the sample
preparation work flow for all mammalian
sample types allowing you to quickly
establish the conditions for your cell
line and as a result you do not need to
continuously re optimize the fixation
and shearing conditions on an ongoing
basis and briefly I wanted to touch upon
our standardized tissue chip workflow
which Cece covered very nicely in her
presentation we have validated this
workflow and our troopship chromatin
sharing tissue kit protocol this
workflows very simple quick and easy to
start you insert your tissue into the
kouvaris tissue bag this bag is made of
a polymer that can withstand extremely
cold temperatures allowing the tissue to
be flash frozen in liquid nitrogen and
pulverized dry to bypass any
cross-contamination issues and again
just looking at the workflow the first
step again is you have to bag and then
to you use the cryo prep and step 2 as
you can see to homogenize the tissue and
then the contents of that material is
moved to a transfer tube in step 3 for
lysis fall by chromatin sharing with a
co virus focus ultrasonic ater the shear
chromatin chromatin is then ready for IP
with your antibodies after IP the cross
links are reversed by treating the
sample with heat prones k to digest the
proteins and i mean any nucleuses that
may be present the DNA is purified with
a pcr purification kit and now is ready
for library prep and again just want to
highlight the three main reagent kits
that are available for use including our
ultra-low chromatin sharing kit which is
optimized for processing less than 100
thousand cells again this is for cells
culture as a suspension or as I'm
hearing and then our standard kit are 5
201 54 which processes 1 to 30 million
cells per sample
and finally our true chip tissue kit
which can be used to process low tissue
masses of around 50 milligrams and all
the way up to 120 milligrams and the
Regents and this kit come the kit comes
with all the regions and buffers
required to carry out the fixation
nuclei prep and chromatin sharing steps
of the workflow as you can see in
parentheses that gives you an indication
of how many reactions you get depending
on what volume you are actually sharing
in so you get 250 if you're doing
between for example 1 to 50 reactions if
you're doing between 1 3 million cells
in that in our micro tube 130 and
the adaptive focus acoustic technology
is Co viruses core technology our Cove
are our focus ultrasonic Gators are
extremely versatile allowing the
investigators to process multiple sample
inputs variety of downstream
applications a si sterilizes your next
generation sequencing sample prep
workflow for a variety of sequencing
applications including whole genome
whole exome and amplicon sharing a phase
probably many commercially available
library prep packet preparation
workflows including Illumina Rubicon
genomics newgen Swift and Agilent
Technologies and in addition if they can
be used to actively extract nucleic
acids from FFPE tissues or plasma to
isolate
cell free DNA using our true extract
products for translational and clinical
sample preparation analysis AFA can also
be used to light cells and small tissues
to extract biomarkers such as proteins
for mass spec and immunoassays in
addition to that RNA can also be shared
using AFA for RNA seek instead of using
divalent cations and heat providing a
much more simplified workflow and we
offer instruments for low throughput
such as our M 220 on the Left which
processes one sample per run medium
throughput which process rme 220 which
processes up to eight samples per run
and that our high throughput workflow
our hard to it throughput instruments
such as the le 220 plus focus ultrasound
occator which processes up to 96 samples
per run with 8 samples processed
simultaneously and because our webinar
is focused on F of genetics I wanted to
share with you other applications that
can be performed using our products that
may be of interest to you in addition to
the use for chips each chip qpcr AFA can
also be used to process samples for DNA
methylation analysis using methyl seek
and we have part of the Agilent protocol
as an example whole genome bisulfite
sequencing and other chromatin
applications such as high seed for
chromatin architects architecture
studies short seek and rip seek and
depending on your laboratories
throughput and applications and sample
types your quarries representative can
help determine the most appropriate
instrument for your laboratory if you're
interested in learning more please visit
our website at
calls and other resources that will be
helpful for fine for information if
you'd like to reach your local sales
manager please email your regional
customer service team listed here or
contact me directly via email and phone
and I'd be more than willing to assist
you you can also follow Polaris on
social media platforms including Twitter
Facebook Linkedin in YouTube where
helpful resources are posted routinely
so without further ado I let's get
started with the Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now again just
as a reminder to ask a question click on
the answer a question box located on the
far left corner of your screen type your
question into the box and hit Send so
let's get started I'm already seeing
some questions coming in CC so I'm going
to start reading them to you and we'll
get sorry yeah
so let's see the first question is what
is the range of good concentration of
sheared chromatin when using mouse brain
tissue um so with DNA um that you want
to did a lot of factors that could not
could change this range so if you have
about 25 to 50 micrograms of DNA that
should be enough but it also depends on
like how much of the protein so I mainly
based my chips using protein
concentration rather than DNA
concentration since I knew that my
protein was was very abundant in the
region that I I tested and so like I
about 300 micrograms of protein which is
enough to do a type II and but that also
depends on if you're like the tissue
ties and the quality of the antibody and
Elven and your epitope integrity so like
I can't I don't have an exact range of
but you just you would want to maximize
your chances with both your person of
interest and your DNA binding site is a
mocha
yes I think if the it will yes
so if yeah because it's not about just
the concentrate this just the amount of
DNA oh all right other factors that
affect it yeah and the next question is
what is the best way to get enough
concentration of chromatin and maybe you
could speak on what you were doing
previously and how it was difficult to
get enough chromatin with your previous
method and speak to that a little bit as
well and how that was affected by your
previous method yes of you right so now
so now I'm getting about three to four
micrograms of of protein from thirty to
forty one grams of tissue and before I
was only getting um like 200 nano grams
of protein um and I think one of the
biggest factors is keeping the tissue
frozen and so I take the tissue out of
now using the covers a protocol I take
the tissue out and I section my tissue
and with the help of liquid nitrogen so
it's frozen all the way through onto a
text you want to fix it safe um from
deterioration but before I was using a
um the plunger uh was that called Theia
and down to majide' oh yes homogenizer
and so um so it's like all of the a
group even if it's not ice like you're
exposing all of those cells to to
temperatures that could degrade the
proteins and so I think the main
difference between this huge increase in
DNA approaching about getting is um
keeping the tissue as cold as possible
and basically completely frozen until
it's fixed okay the next question
actually I can see the person's name now
so the next question comes from Claudia
and her question is from the starting
material of 30 to 40 milligrams do you
run one full experiment including
controls and do you advise storing share
chromatin for further chip assays
yes so from one from audience oohs yeah
so from one mouth I can get about a
three to four mo micro grams of protein
and that's enough to run of both the IP
and the IgG I don't know as much about
about sequencing using that much which
may be how me could comment later on but
for like a four qPCR it's it's plenty -
and you could do a couple of genes I
would say like four to five depending
again on the abundance of your um your
approach yes in the region the next
question comes from be Jung from Johns
Hopkins and he's asking what volume did
you use for IP was at 500 my clear is
one mil or two mils
what long face oh um so for IP I used um
three hundred microliters okay I'm just
in the 1.5 1.5 Michael ear - but the key
to that is that you want to make sure
that it's advocated and very well
agitated all throughout overnight okay
the next question comes from Monica and
it is what other genes were linked to
CeMAT 3 in the chip rtq PCR data
so I shall set out to to sell turbines
to manager markings we picked one my
name because it was the most compatible
with within the 11 but we also tested
out some housekeeping genes such as a
gap th and H HP RT and so um these
housekeeping genes of one of them were
found actually a decrease as well with
stress and then a Inc and the other one
would didn't find it decrease with not
three but both of them are affected by
the stress levels guys are binding yeah
this is not a good question from being
at Johns Hopkins is he's asking are the
antibodies that you used for IPL chip
grade or did you use any or did you any
of them that do not say chip grade also
work maybe speak to how well
characterize the antibody actually has
to be referred to be for jet the
antibody is for chip um all throughout
is the same antibody for my three
experiments my EMSA Western blot and
chip qPCR and that was a chip grade
antibody but when I did a SuperSearch
essay with my answer at experiment it
didn't actually work
so for these experiment it was that
antibody worked perfectly fine okay so I
haven't tested I know like not trip
grade antibody but you can also what I
do is I just call the company because
sometimes they um they have information
about papers that other people have sent
them using that antibody after five
experiments that I'm not published okay
the next question is from Celia and I'm
going to direct it to me do you have
experience with paraffin-embedded tissue
samples and can speak to that workflow
that we do have me I think that's a very
good question we there's clearly two
publications often which decide Cove
ours for tip from FFPE samples we can
certainly provide you those reference
but also in the next couple of weeks we
should have a an application to note
that will be published with a group that
is very successfully doing chip from
FFPE samples and even lasered micro
dissected sections of AP sections
carrying successful chip and we're also
going to be soon introducing a kit for
FFPE chip fairly soon we should be able
to have that kit within the next quarter
so those are very good questions
I think if you have any further
questions on tip from FFPE please get in
touch with Sean and you should be able
to send you the material when it's
available thank you thank you Hameed the
next question is from mingling and it's
what's the ratio of total input protein
and antibody use for IP um so input
protein uh I can't remember this exactly
I think usually a five micrograms is the
what is what I use the pet again
depending on how much of the target
protein that you have in your sample
um and the impro protein I used was um
so 300 is enough to do an IP but since I
was using a body clonal antibody I
decided to increase the portion amount
so I used 600 grams of protein was I
think it was
I don't remember the exact amount of
antibody that I use but it was I can I
can send that to you via email later the
details
okay we're going to take one last
question and it is from Sam from the
University of Delaware for experimental
5hmc treatment how much of the double
strand DNA gets altered with 5hmc and
then how does this alteration relate to
5hmc found in vivo that's a long
question yeah it's a great question also
for the experimental treatment it was
only 30 gauge pairs of in the middle of
it was the binding site and then only
once I Regency was at one on each side
of the double strand DNA was added that
was enough to influence to decrease I
almost have the binding of map through
to that probe and in terms of in vivo as
you can see on unpaid here let me go to
that slide as you can see on this slide
right here
so this slide has the yellow is um the
binding site so we included the
violation see that's such that size base
pairs away from the binding site and
extended that to circulation but however
in vivo there's all these other sites
around that could be modified and it
might be it might be different as the
effects might be even stronger and um
orphan size agency usually have a
prospect then of a cluster of five
agency okay there is just one last
question and it's from Joseph from
venture near Commonwealth University
your question is is the ultra low
chromatin method suitable for laser
capture microdissection Micro selected
samples and the answer to your question
is yes if you have more questions please
reach out to us directly we'd be happy
to help you with that
and then so I just want to thank you
again Cece for this fantastic webinar
you did a truly fantastic job and do you
have any final
comments for the audience about today's
presentation just a one last comment of
this book I saw the interest I um this
issue this topic is really interesting
and saivation see is emerging since 2009
and it's a really great target to to
studies for mental illness which is a
big problem in our society and so if I
need you know can't your graduate
students who are interested in looking
at a topic to study could continue this
research that would be great
excellent I know to me yeah I know so it
again this took a hot like took two
years to incisor protocol so don't give
up when you think that is going to not
work it might just the one thing you can
buy just you around the corner it's very
good advice and how me do you have any
final comments as well before we go yes
I tip a tip is difficult application to
optimize so I think what we've done is
we've we have come up with a very good
and universal solution for chip from
tissues and cultured cells from
mammalian to tissues and cells that work
quite well so if anyone is having issues
with chip reproducibility or even
epitope integrity please feel free to
contact us so we would be very happy to
help you thank you excellent yes and
before we go I'd like to once again
thank the audience for joining us today
and for the interesting questions we've
received in the Q&A session and any
questions that we did not answer today
that comment during the on-demand period
will be addressed via email by the
speaker and if you have any specific
product related questions as Hameed
mentioned about any issues that you're
having with your chip and other
epigenetic based workflows please
contact us directly and you can reach me
at my information which was on the last
slide and before we go kouvaris would
like to thank lab roots for making this
webinar possible please know that this
webinar will be available to be viewed
on-demand until actually november of
2018 and Labyrinth will alert you via
email when today's presentation is
available for replay we encourage you to
share the email with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event and
we hope you have a wonderful day thank
you again so much to CC for the
fantastic job that she did today it was
really a great presentation and I hope
everyone enjoyed it yeah
very thank you